allora dovrei avere tutto ma per
sicurezza facciamo un ultimo set
[Musica]
occhiali li abbiamo accessori abbiamo
trucchi sera trucchi giorno perfetto
outfit per direi che posso partire
domani andiamo al mare al mare o
minimizzare
dobbiamo andare a ballare schiaccia
marino hai fatta la valigia sì adesso la
faccio uno che se non porti tra mezz'ora
non perdi quell'aereo aiuto lo dico come
perdono
ma dovrà essere tutto però aiuta bettino
per fare pilates lo porterei perché non
si sa mai perché pilates è molto bello
non l'ho mai fatto però potrebbe esserci
l'opportunità la tuta da sci pure perché
ok che siamo al mare ma metti che
qualcuno manda fare una gita in alta
quota
io ci devo ci devo andare devo essere
preparata carta da pacchi perché non si
sa mai che qualcuno festeggia il
compleanno carta igienica perché insomma
essenziale e non si sa mai magari in
albergo la sinistra
maledetta il russo privo park
deve chiudere questo cio pesa troppo
devo togliere qualcosa paillettes e
paillettes le paillettes fra
effettivamente non ho mai messo neanche
qua quindi magari minori e tornerà
giannino mia bronzo tanto quindi magari
non gli sta tanto i beni con internate
potrai toglierlo già due poi avanti così
[Musica]
tre valigie per una settimana dovrebbero
bastare
però questa la potevo portare sia 4 noi
capitolando due compagni per il giorno 2
però la sera poi a bikini 1 e gli stand
ho temuto anche perché tanto poi le lato
mascara ma di avere sopracciglia e
fondotinta perché basta e avanza e
perché resti un pareggio ma sembrano un
pò eli stone e un cappello il forno lo
porto perché vado dal 4 e basta finito
15 giovani basta e avanza
è inutile spendere i vestiti è molto più
semplice così piccoli piccoli rotolini
posizionati uno vicino all'altro buona
occupano meno spazio chi puoi portare
più roba arma l'impero riporta questa la
adoro e rotolini mamma di genio di tutor
a fare la valigia
basta con questa valigia devi imparare
ma non solo con l'anci ti prego vi va
bene va bene arrivo al la valigia sono e
cosa mettere l'occhiataccia di natasha
che vi pare che il mio segreto riva
schermo diciamolo molte tavole scampini
dove eravamo rimasti
estro porto
l'uomo che è carinissimo tiri moquette e
adesso li mando tutti mi è sempre
piaciuto giocare a tetris da dove
partiamo questa qui e qui
poi è nulla qui poi la borsa e ci sta
ancora l'altro vestito che non riusciva
portar monni ma sono proprio in un genio
un genio delle valigie stop perfetto
ti prego fate ci stia tutto in valigia è
veramente il minimo indispensabile per
me è tutto così fondamentale t3 non vi
chiedo più niente ma fa che si chiuda
questo benedetto fallito e soprattutto
che non superi mettete tiri perché io
non ho un euro e non posso pagarlo
sovrappeso però voglio tutto allora
beauty case
il mio mascara preferito in versione
mini c'è la matita per le sopracciglia
fondamentale anche terra abbronzante
pure eyeliner fondo tinta nove ragazzi
da quando ho scoperto i prodotti
migliori benefit ho svoltato le vacanze
sì perché sono mini suoi prodotti che
uso durante tutto l'anno ma in forma
todini quindi occupano meno spazio e ho
più spazio in valigia per mettere quel
tocco in più e tra l'altro hanno anche
un prezzo mini qui sono perfetti per
tutti coloro che vogliono provarli per
la prima volta senza per forza
acquistare la versione dei size niente
veti che ho fatto è
si parte fatemi sapere con un commentino
qui sotto a quali queste tipologie
appartenete il mi raccomando godetevi
quest'estate e buone vacanze
io vi mando un bacione stoppa d'oro ciao
[Musica]